that's chris hunter but this is the
question
stephen kinonos francis scott key who
wrote the anthem
was a slave owner and most people didn't
know that
last that to last five years so what's
so that's what drives people crazy and
want to change
the america the beautiful soyboy mafia
hashtag so your community
yeah let me give the answer to that my
perspective just so you know
assyrians were slave owners blacks were
slave owners
jews were slave owners you go back
200 years ago 300 years ago every
culture on slaves every
culture on slaves there is not one that
never owned slaves
africa owned slaves they do many small
till today there are many countries that
own slaves what are we gonna do
so now we have to get rid of all the
history of everybody that at one point
had it is that what we're gonna be doing
so so what if right now somebody said
that
this one large insurance company that's
one of our competitors
and they've been around since 1868. okay
it's based out of new york hence
you okay so did you know
that back in the days they sold life
insurance to
slave owners so one of my guys said
we should use that when we're going up
against our competitors and bring that
up i said you're never going to do that
why because if they did it other people
did it
that was legal back then it was stupid
it was not good it wasn't anything that
we agree with today
but back then it was what legal
okay very simple legal and if it was
illegal back then no one is breaking
what
the law okay very simple so does it mean
we endorse it
of course not does it mean we support it
absolutely not
does it mean we sit there and we say oh
my gosh you know it's it's
so who cares no that's not what we're
saying it wasn't a law
back then so large insurance companies
uh what do you call it they sold
insurance to slave owners
should we shut all of them down all the
banks here
all the banks in america every single
one of them bank of america bank of
italy used to be bank of italy
so every single one of the banks in
america finance and help open up
accounts for slave owners should we shut
down all the banks
should we shut down all the bank that's
what we should do so every book you ever
read that's an old book
okay we're talking about 200 years ago
that are classics
oh somebody in their family should we
get rid of that book so is this the
direction we're gonna go
so so a crime everybody committed now we
should bring you back and because of
that embarrassed in public is that the
direction we're going
again that is a form of a nuclear war
because if you constantly go and say but
you did this
79 years ago but you did this 200 years
ago look at what happened kevin hart
who didn't want to see kevin hart do the
oscars who didn't want to see him as the
host
everybody wanted to see him do be the
host but no back in 2014 here's what
kevin r tweeted are you kidding me
and then they went through what they did
with kevin hart now so
to me it is part of the tradition it's
what we've used
everybody and anybody that we know on
their resume there is something bad
including yourself kenyon i bet you if i
were to go and do hire somebody fifty
thousand dollars and i told him your
project is to go investigate to see what
bad things you did i guarantee we would
bring out some things that you wouldn't
be happy with
i mean we're human we're not perfect
that's the point of us are perfect we
make mistakes that's just the way it is
what's that one song
i'm only human born to make mistakes
it's one of the best commercials uh and
i think another thing there is kind of
you're judging the past with today's
perspective and today's
values and principles that we have or
our viewpoints
right now which just doesn't make sense
because times
change things that are okay in the past
aren't okay now and vice versa things
that are okay now
aren't weren't okay then so you're just
you're confusing the times and how
you look at things and in that case
there's going to be wrong
things with everything i mean again
we're human we're not perfect
we make mistakes and at different points
in time
those things are okay or those things
are normal watch this
i can't hear my okay thank you so what
is february
black history black history month yeah
okay america do you know what percentage
of americans are african-american
are african 13 exactly good number
that's the number 13.4 percent
do you know what percentage of our
company are african-american out of our
eighteen thousand
thirty percent twenty twenty two percent
between twenty to twenty two percent
fifty percent latino fifty percent
latino twenty to twenty percent
african-american right okay twenty
percent white where we at
you guys are up there okay like top five
no no not you guys
but but it's top five but here's the
point i'm trying to make to you
does this mean that we don't have
you know 50 of the company to be white
that
we're racist again like you understand
what i'm saying like what are you going
to do every time you're racist against
somebody
every company you know like but this sun
this month is black history month so the
teacher asks my son
uh which character do you want to write
a report about
for black history month at the school
that he's going to so him and my wife
are having a conversation together
and my son says because my son has read
a lot of books on martin luther king any
book i get that i can give my martin
luther king i want
yeah i want him to read it so
he says i want to write about martin
luther king jen says
why don't you try somebody else because
everybody else is doing martin luther
king
he says okay he comes back he says you
know what mom i want to do it on rosa
parks
he said this yesterday he said okay son
so he's doing his report
on rosa parks hasn't how does he know
about rosa parks he's read multiple
books on rosa parks why because we want
to teach him
the history of america we don't sit
there and say don't read this
you know read this here's what happened
dude i went and seen the real bus of
rosa parks that was i went to the bus
where
it was in dearborn it's in ford museum
eric and i drove
as we were driving here and he gave me a
lot of crap for this was because we were
driving through alabama
and i saw we were about to pass
montgomery and then selma was further
south so i was like let's just drive
through selma
and uh pete something bridge where they
the famous bridge where they marched
over it
we drove over it and kind of just
checked out the area so absolutely
there's there's a lot you can learn
and there's a lot you can you have to
kind of know of it to not resp repeat
the mistakes what's the quote
those who don't read history repeat
history yep
adam i think even just what we're doing
right now
you're giving your perspective you're
giving your perspective i'm giving my
perspective
we all have different perspectives it's
important
i'm not saying you're 100 right you're
100 wrong it's important to talk things
out one thing that stands out to me
even on the podcast i remember when we
were during the middle
of all the protests george floyd they
were going down and removing
a lot of the confederate statues ruining
them all and you asked me a question
should the confederate statues
be removed and listen no fan of
confederacy
whatsoever like not even close um and i
give a very emotional
response and i hell yeah take them down
get the hell out of here
and people like what do you mean take
them down i'm like get them out get [ __ ]
them
and then after cooler heads prevailed i
listened to some other perspectives
i re-thought my perspective i
re-analyzed my stance of this i said you
know what
they should go in a museum for history
if you want to learn there's a
confederate
museum over there we can't cancel the
past we can learn from it if you're not
if you don't learn from history you're
destined to repeat it
so i remember on another podcast i gave
a um
a reform my answer and i said well you
know i thought about it
and i'd like to reverse course and i you
know i don't think they should just
remove everything but i don't think it
should be out there in the public
to be grandstanded on like these are
these people who aren't heroes at the
end of the day they were traitors
but it is part of our history so put it
in a museum
you know if you want to learn about it
go for it so
what's important is to have a
conversation to hear your thoughts to
hear my thoughts
to hear the blm social justice thoughts
to hear
why you know the the south will rise
again hear their perspective talk it out
i did an interview with daryl davis
the most important thing you can do is
respect somebody's opinion
and be willing to listen you might
disagree but hear them out and when you
can talk
to somebody and you can have an open
dialogue that's where you'll find some
compromise in the middle
the kanto culture up get out you're out
go uh but that's where we are though
that's where we are it's a very
dangerous life fortunately that's what
we ask
i told robert kiyosaki i said we are
living in the walk and walking on actual
society
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]
you